let's start off by thanking the
organizers very much for looks like a
potentially great day I'm going to learn
a great deal from it and it's
fascinating to be here so this is a
joint paper with Anthony you'll be
hearing directly from him later on
anyway the idea is to give a kind of
very general overview of not a lot of
detail of how he Cana mists think about
uncertainty and of what Antonia and I
know about unscientific uncertain how
that sort of plays into the way
columnist think about uncertainty so a
look which would I go this whoops what
did I hit the bottom one again ah so to
go forward what I pressed right okay
there we are so there's two messages and
just in case I don't get to the end of
my talk I thought I'd put the
conclusions of the front rather than the
back to messages from this any message
to economist and a message to scientists
message to economists is that
uncertainty is really very fundamental
and the area of climate changed it's not
a second-order thing effect it's
absolutely first-order effect and it
really affects the way we think about
the problem and it affects the kinds of
questions we can ask effects where we go
about modeling things in the climate
area now in Flex even as this here the
way we pose problems exactly what that
means I'm not totally certain myself
think it's an area it's a research area
but I'm going to come up with in about
10 minutes I'll give you some
suggestions on what I think that means
but they're very tentative suggestions
and I think that one of the active areas
of research for the sort of decision
making community should be really how
exactly do we grapple with the
uncertainty and how does it affect the
kinds of questions we can ask the kinds
of answers we can be looking for the
climate scientists you know we
economists are not getting the
information we need and I'll sort of try
to give you some sense of that later on
but in particular the IPCC has
historically focused very much on
central tendencies when it's talking
about about outputs of climate models I
think the latest report I haven't
studied as much detail as Ken as seems
to be little bit better on that making
some progress but point i'm going to
make which is a point that for example
Marty here has really made very
frequently and much more articulate than
iron i'm going to i think is that the
sort of uncertainty we're dealing with
means that outlying events and extreme
events can be extreme
important and economic decisions can be
very much very strongly influenced by
extreme outcomes and we really need
information about the extremes of a
distribution as much as we need
information about the central tendencies
of a distribution and it's absolutely
critical and most IPCC assessments and
many scientific assessments really punt
on what are the outer limits of the
distribution but from an economic
perspective these are the disasters and
these are the things that really can
motivate policy choices and political
decisions so we need more on that stuff
so I want to talk about that's just
that's the message okay um just in case
I don't get that so I want to talk about
two things with two concerts risk and
ambiguity used to be called risk and
uncertainty so a fascinating book from
the 1930s called about risk and
uncertainty Uncle Frank night made the
distinction between risk and uncertainty
where risk is where you know the
probabilities and uncertain is where you
don't have any probabilities but the
outcome is still stochastic and
unpredictable uncertainties God kind of
you know use for too many things since
then with that distinction to make much
sense today so the modern replacement
for uncertainty is ambiguity so risk is
the form will they give you a choice of
ten dollars with certainty or 50-50
chance of five or fifteen dollars then
almost anybody will choose the ten
dollars for 70 right so I can then ask
the question for what X is 10 minus X
the same to you as the 50-50 chance of 5
or 15 and that the value of that X is
what we call a measure of risk aversion
how much you're willing to pay to avoid
a risk ok what's ambiguity so now your
choice is ten dollars of a certainty or
five dollars with probability P and
fifteen dollars with probability 1 minus
P where P is unknown and a P was point
five before now you don't know what P is
it could be anything anywhere in 01 okay
and I ask you the same question for what
why is 10 minus V indifferent 25 the
probability P and 15 with probability 1
minus P where you don't know what P is
it's a well posed question I can ask you
that question first guy to ask that
question seriously in saudia was a guy
called Daniel Ellsberg back in the 1960s
famous the Pentagon Papers there's
actually very good economist to anyway
so that's that's the question and you
know doesn't you get a
to that it's why and typically we find
that Y is quite a lot bigger than X
people are averse to ambiguity they
don't like being put in situation's
where they don't know the probabilities
and either argued in the climate field
were somewhere in between these you know
we don't have we certainly don't know
the probabilities of the various
outcomes but the same time we don't have
no current information about the
probabilities either we have some
information about the probabilities but
not full information about the
probabilities if we like we have
probabilities over probabilities and the
question is how do you make decisions
rationally in that kind of situation so
what are the sources of uncertainty I'm
not going to tell you anything at all
new here so I apologize for that but
maybe just as useful to systematize them
anyway so the we distinguish between
will be called scientific uncertainty
and socio economic uncertainty pretty
obvious distinction right scientific and
certainly as far as we can understand it
and there's plenty of people here we can
probably correct us on this you can
break down into three sources what we
call internal variability I you know
sort of climate models weather models
display sensitive dependence on initial
conditions so exactly where you start
these things off from can have a big
impact on where they turn out to a few
years from now there's modeling
uncertainty we don't know what the right
structural models are exactly you
basically understand the physics but
exactly how you implement the physics
can vary a great deal you can't
implement the physics in great detail
you're going to make approximations and
simplifications and different people
make different choices in that area so
we've got what we call modeling
uncertainty and finally of course
there's emissions pathway uncertainty
the whole phenomenon is driven by the
levels of greenhouse gas emissions and
we don't know what those will be in the
future so those are the various sources
of scientific uncertainty socio economic
uncertainty we decompose into what we
call positive or empirical uncertainty
and normative uncertainty so positive in
Pyrrhic on certain uses we don't really
understand how the socio-economic
systems are going to respond to the
various parameters of climate change
it's not just a question the temperature
many aspects of the human impacts of
climate change its precipitation it's
wind speeds it's humidity and stuff like
that the measures of matters as much as
temperature which into summarizes all by
the temperature variable so
we don't understand you know how human
systems respond to those and there's
also normative uncertainty you know when
we're doing evaluations of economic
policies in the climate area and we have
to make certain assumptions about
parameters you know what rate should we
discount the future what number should
we pick for an index a risk aversion
those are sort of choices that reflect
our value judgments and is actually
quite a lot of disagreement amongst
about those there's plenty of people in
this room on the economic side had
chosen different values for these
parameters and their models at various
stages and it makes a huge difference
you know whether you discount things a
hundred years from now at one percent
per annum or a three percent branham
makes a huge huge difference to how
important they are so there's actually
some bona fide a if you might want
called a normative or ethical
uncertainty in these sort of the
socio-economic evaluation as well okay
um let's talk about some of these things
so you've just heard about the
equilibrium climate sensitivity and this
is the diagram that can showed you I
skip to the description of that because
can describe it came from a paper that
well the basic data is a paper by
mainsails until a few years back and
then Anthony and I used it again and
repair ammeter eyes dad the interesting
thing about this is that you know what
you've got here is some PDFs probability
density functions over the ecs generated
by a range of different climate models
and you know there's some similarity
obviously most of them have their the
bulk of their the probability somewhere
in this sort of one to four and a half
degree range which is reassuring and
that's what the IPCC reports to us but
from economic perspective what is
actually really quite interesting and
potentially even quite scary the amount
of stuff you've got up here the amount
of stuff you've got in the sort of four
five six degree ecs range and obviously
an ecs in that range there is dangerous
means that the impact of climate change
could be absolutely massive we could
have in Marty's terminology climate
catastrophe and this huge disagreement I
mean those guys up here are giving sort
of almost zero percent to this as a
probability those guys are pure of
giving ten percent to this is a
probability now obviously we understand
that then you know the right-hand
endpoint of these distribution is
probably less well constrained by the
data
TenPoint the left-hand endpoint is where
we are today and the right-hand endpoint
is way outside of any practical
experience but nevertheless from a
decision makers perspective this stuff
up here really matters you know we
really would like to know whether there
is a one-percent chance of a truly
disastrous outcome or a five percent
chance of a truly disastrous outcome
makes a big difference when you're
trying to sell the idea of climate
change policies to politicians and the
public as a whole makes a big difference
the kinds of calculations that guys like
Bill and can and Marty and I go through
very big difference in deep that's so
stuff we need to know and what is you
know challenging from my perspective
when I look at a diagram like this is
you know on the basis of this
information here how do I make a
probabilistic calculation in which of
these distributions do i use clear I
can't click any particular one do I
average them for average them I lose
information averaging them is not the
right thing to do I somehow need to use
all of the information in these
distributions to make a decision without
obviously sort of giving picking any
particular one as the right one and
that's you know that's from a
decision-making perspective were the
intellectual challenges I I don't have a
probability distribution but I have some
probabilistic information and I want to
know how to use it and at this point
actually don't really know how to do
that i guess i was like i said i'll give
you some ideas but it's it's that's
where the challenge is i think on our
side of the house um so you know this is
this slide just says things which i
think a pretty obvious about about what
I just had up let's talk about some
other sources of uncertainty this is uh
okay this is a diagram that comes from
flip crud through this i'll talk about
it when I've got the diagram up for some
reason okay so this is a Hawkins and
Sutton diagram what we've got here is a
an attempt to break down uncertainty
about future forecasts for to focus of
the future temper proposes of a global
mean temperature by Li Tong so if you're
forecasting 20 years ahead 40 years and
it's 60 years 88 years a hundred years
ahead what are the principal sources of
uncertainty
and as we're breaking this down into the
three types of uncertainty I talked
about just now uncertain derived from
inter internal variability which is the
orange part uncertainty derived from the
emissions pathway which is the green
part and uncertainty derived from
uncertainty about the the model choice
the right choice of model which is this
part here and what this paper does is it
try to show us how the uncertainty
associated forecast of the future can be
broken down in but amongst those three
sources i was talking about before and
it was he that breakdown depends very
much on the time toward you're looking
at for really short time horizons you
know emission the path uncertainty it's
not a particularly big deal and we have
dominated by model uncertainty with a
certain amount of initial condition
uncertainty initial conditions
uncertainty dies are ways that by the
last third of a century it's really not
a big issue and were left with almost a
50-50 split between uncertainty about
the basic structural model we're working
with and uncertainty about what
emissions pathway will will be working
with and so those are the two dominant
things and of course mission pathway and
certainty is effectively a former socio
economic uncertainty because we don't
know what policies were going to
actually sort of manage to persuade
people to implement so that said so
we're breaking down I'll the scientific
uncertainty another interesting aspect
of scientific uncertainty but again it's
actually quite important to economists
is this stuff from the paper by mass on
a new T the dependence of uncertainty on
on geographic scale on spatial scale and
the point is that uncertainly is
measured by the intermodal spread in the
predictions of either temperature on the
left or precipitation on the right and
the the key point here is that the
intermodal spread is a a decreasing
function of the scale of the predictions
she make really big scale predictions at
the Continental level the models agree
reasonably precisely soon as you get
into kind of more detailed lower level
smaller smaller areas the models begin
to disagree quite strongly some example
I was involved in a an assessment and
attempt to make a relatively detailed
climate forecast at some point for the
the Gulf states in the US states on the
Gulf of Mexico so the that's a
relatively small scale by the 60s
if I of global circulation models and
you know there was general agreement
amongst the models there on the
temperature change over 50 years over a
hundred years but some models bachelor
predicting an increase in precipitation
and others were predicting a decrease in
precipitation when go down with that
scope and that's the big difference and
if you're going to tell the inhabitants
of the Gulf state which climate change
means for them you better go I've got to
know whether they're going to get wetter
or drier as a fairly basic product
parameter but as you try to get down to
some more specific scales which is the
scales that matter to human decision
makers and the scales of matter to
voters and in individuals then the
uncertainty really blows up and that's
what these things are such showing us
again and that seems to be a fundamental
problem with the resolution of the
climate models but it might be really
interested to hear I bought what the
prospects are for doing better on this
seems like an interesting issue
important bishop anyways that's some
comments on the scientific sources of
uncertainty and what number the article
seem to say is that that hasn't you know
that these sources of uncertainty a
fundamental aren't going to go away
anyone the near future so we're going to
have to live with some of these sources
of uncertainty um social economic
uncertainty I've already sort of given
you an approve an outline on this I
think I can go through this very quickly
and get perhaps to the what this means
for decision making let me skip that too
so what we're trying to do here as I
said is to find some way of making
decisions about how to how to use
limited probabilistic information in
making kind of rational choices of
policies and that catchy that's a
question which goes back quite a long
way it goes back to the 1930s actually
what's called walked by wall the
statistician and his choice what's
called the maximum criteria and to
savage in his book on the foundation
statistics in 1953 i guess it was and
all these guys develops probability free
approaches to making decisions all of
which generally focus on the worst case
now we don't want something which is
probability free in this area we want
some which is probability light it's not
any different from probability free but
in let's talk about the probability free
cases for start-up because that's a good
place to start over
so the these these first these things
mentioned the first bullet point you're
all essentially talk about how to make
decisions when there isn't a lot of
probabilistic information or there's no
probabilistic information and you know
basically what these guys all do and
there's a trigger is to sort of set out
a set of axioms which they believe
describe rational behavior in the
absence of probabilities or on the
limpet of limited amount of
probabilistic information and then from
these axioms they kind of deduce what is
the right criterion to maximize how to
think rationally about how to think
about this and so one of the oldest
recommendations is in this areas that we
pursue what's called the max min
strategy it's a reach possible policy we
look at the worst outcome and then we
pick the policy use worst outcome is
least bad so that's was acts Emma ties
my arrow and hurvitz back in 1970s and
she urgently goes back to wall the 1930s
you know it's a nice approach it offers
some insurance against disaster by
focusing on worst-possible-case outcomes
but you know if the probability of a
worst-case outcome is really really
small then you're letting the tail wag
the dog in effect and that might not be
a rational thing to do but you know
going back to my earlier points about
the information we need you can see that
you know if you took this approach then
we're not particularly trusted in mean
outcomes we're interested in extreme
outcomes so we don't to know what the
right hand side of the distribution of
ecs is we're not interested in what it's
mean is if this is the decision-making
rule were making ok now there's another
approach which is a bit more
sophisticated than this is so this that
particular approach has been implemented
in a version of bills dice model that
haven't got time to talk about that
another version of this is what's called
the min-max regret model which goes back
to savage in his book on foundations of
stance you define regrets associate with
any any particular policy as the
difference between particular state is
the difference between what you're
actually getting in that state and what
you could have got if you've known
accidentally what the state was going to
be being you chosen the optimal policy
can outgrow that and then you basically
do a min max operation over that so it's
a similar idea but slightly more
sophisticated but you're still throwing
away any probable
stick information and again it's still
the case if you want to implement this
kind of decision making rule you get you
need information about extremes much
more than you need information about
means so that's the kind of take away
show for the scientific community for
you more recently there's been a bunch
of approaches to this way of thinking
about things it's just some examples or
that thinking about these things which
you watch called multiple priors so this
is an example of situation you well
you've got multiple priors you know
prior is some priors that make Santa
estimate of a distribution here we've
got 20 people's estimates of what this
distribution is how do you make a
rational choice when you've got multiple
distributions like this multiple prior
distributions again I haven't but this
is a complex sophisticated literature
and I'm going to give you some ribbon in
about two minutes so there's a couple of
different ways about going up going
about this basically what you've got to
do is look at all of those distributions
and one way of approaching this you look
at the distribution which gives you the
worst possible outcome was possible
value for any particular policy and you
evaluate your policy by that worst
distribution so and if you think looking
at a policy of cutting bank admissions
by a certain percent over time you say
okay let's evaluate this against all
possible probability distributions all
that are consistent with what we know
and will actually well the value will
attach to it is the one attached to the
worst of these at least favorable
distributions that's what's called max
min utility and there's a nice
axiomatization of that by a couple of
decision theories billboards and
schneider goes back to the 1990s so what
you're doing there is basically doing a
kind of expecting deter the calculation
but using the least favorable prior and
again that isn't an extreme thing to do
that's something which comes out of a
set of axioms which are quite carefully
thought out and are quite nice axioms
actually happy to talk about them more
later another way of looking about this
is which is what's called the smoothing
majority approach is to take all of
these priors and rather than focusing on
the worst one give them weights you know
evaluate a policy of each of those
possible priors each of those 20
distributions we have example in the
previous slide but give those
distributions weights and say you know
this is more likely this is less likely
and we'll take a sort of weighted
average of the outcomes according to
these various distributions
so we may want to give more weight to
the worse than to the best that's a
subjective issue since the kind of role
for subjective judgment in that approach
there so those are the the basic kinds
of approaches we've got those proteins
have all been implemented into the
various economic models at least some
preliminary level I don't think that
exhausts the space by any means and i'm
sure there's approaches to these things
that haven't been thought out yet but um
you know the i guess the bottom line
from this is that you know i gave you a
couple of takeaways up the front it's a
good job I did that cuz I'm out of time
now but the other takeaways it before
you before you model you have to think
very very hard about what information
you have and how you can use it you do
have to give weight to worst cases and
one of the things that does emerge
clearly from the kind of emerging
current literature on decision theory
when you've got limited probabilistic
information is you need to give weight
to the worst cases and you need to work
with multiple probabilistic scenarios ok
that's it I'm out of time I'm very guys
thanks